i have to admit that this story kind of
bums me out
and you'll understand why in a little
bit it relates
it relates to my youth in some sense um
fox business host maria bartoromo
is now sinking so low that that it's
actually depressing
um you i am sure at this point have
heard
that joe biden won the presidential
election that the electoral college
confirmed it
joe biden has most of his cabinet
selected donald trump lost in court
like 50 times or something like that the
supreme court has said no thanks to his
case
and fox business host maria bartoromo
now really a second-rate fox host even
by their standards
is a really aggressive trump brown noser
and claimed yesterday that
an intel source wait for it an
intel source told her donald trump
actually won the election
let's look at the clip and then i'm
going to tell you about the sort of
tragic
downfall of maria bartoroma an intel
source telling me that president trump
did in fact win the election he says
that it
is up to the supreme court to hear suits
from other cases across the country
to stop the clock this follows the high
court's refusal to hear the lawsuit from
texas attorney general ken paxton
challenging results in four swing states
now you might say
well david if an intel source did tell
her that she's not lying she's merely
reporting it
and the intel source could simply be
wrong or mistaken
but is that really the argument you want
to make that's the hill you want to die
on
maria bartiromo is more than 50 years
old and she's been a journalist in some
way shape or form for almost 30 years
and we're standing behind what she said
is okay and responsible to air
as long as some intel person really did
tell her
with no vetting or connection or actual
evidence she says this is what they told
me
it's actually shocking how maria
bartoromo
has fallen from being a great financial
reporter
to being what is in short a conspiracy
theorist trump suck up that's what she
is at this point
and the the way this relates to my youth
is when i first got into trading stocks
back in the year
2000 when i was in high school i started
watching cnbc because i guess that's
what you do
or at least what you did at the time and
at the time
maria bartoromo really did excellent
interviews
of big time fortune 500 ceos she would
hold them accountable
her interview preparation was second to
none she was fantastic
and she was the first tv journalist to
report live from the floor of the new
york stock exchange she won emmys for
that
she was well recognized by the italian
american community in new york city
related to her amazing story working her
way up
from her early days in brooklyn as a kid
being a coat checker at her dad's
restaurant i mean it's just an amazing
story
and she was a top-notch interviewer for
more than a decade
and then she joined fox in 2013 things
sort of started to get a little bit
shaky
but then when trump ran in 2016
she developed like an on-air
relationship with trump and got to
interview donald trump and became
essentially
a a dishonest pr person for donald trump
rather than a journalist which sadly
sometimes happens to people when they go
over to fox news
and it really is sad so here's my my uh
ask of you don't let this happen to me
hold me accountable i don't think it
would happen but i'm telling you right
now if i do something like this
you can go ahead and cancel your
membership it would be embarrassing and
pathetic
to me to my family to the people that
have supported this show but i'm sure
it's lucrative for her
and who doesn't want to have a friend in
the white house right that is that
that's actually one of the things that
sometimes i i think those who
are only very casual observers of media
don't get
which is that the the appeal
of access to people in power
makes media people do really crazy
things
sometimes and i've said before how
i don't really care about being friends
with politicians
there are a number of elected officials
in the u.s house and
in other offices that that i'm in touch
with and
we have what i guess we would call like
personal relationships but
they're not like i'm you know if they do
something wrong and it's even happened
i cover it and i'm not really impressed
i've said we shouldn't deify these
people
but maybe when it gets to a certain
level and it's the president
maybe if the president wants to be your
friend you just repeat whatever nonsense
the president wants you to say i don't
know
uh but it's really a tragedy what's
happened to maria barto-roma